your comments at about batery oh yeah
what uh are you happy to see him go
Senator McCain no I think he's a fine
man and I hope that now the Republican
Party will join together and sit down
and try to resolve our differences all
right do you think he was keeping people
apart or was he trying to bring unity I
think he was trying to bring unity and I
because I'm a great admirer of him in a
very difficult job I hope now that his
legacy will be for us all wings of the
party to sit down together work out our
differences and recognize our job is to
elect one of these dice maybe that's
speaking today as president United
States are you still worried about the
wacko birds as you call them I mean
people like Ted Cruz who's speaking here
today he and I have a very cordial
relationship there's as he will be the
first to attest we don't agree on
everything but well you vote to defund
the government next week over the
Planned Parenthood issue I will not
because I need for someone to tell me
how we can override a presidential veto
eat if we got it to the President's desk
that 51 vote issue is interesting but
the President on States constitutionally
can / can veto and we do not have the
votes to override a veto and I don't
want to shut down the VA
Iko too much to the veterans of this
country to shut down the ability to care
for our veterans are you going to be
able to overturn the Jones Act any time
so thank you for asking
I hate the Jones it's so protectionist
and it creases the cost of every
consumer in America and I thank you for
I thank you for it's a it's a crash it's
the classic example of the influence of
the special interest and can I thank you
for asking that question because we it
has been one of the more that in catfish
have been my two favorite and and sugar
subsidies how much we're spending about
four trillion dollars a year now how
much less should we be spending next
year as
I I can't say that exactly but I can
tell you that if we can get the defense
authorization bill through
it requires cuts in staffs by seven and
a half percent per year that's 30
percent over four year period that would
be well into the billions of dollars we
could save just there in the fence if we
can stop the cost overruns like the
aircraft carrier that had a 2.4 billion
dollar cost overrun we stopped those we
can save billions and that's my area of
responsibility and I'm dedicated to is
the f-35 is that a program that should
just be mothballed and get on with
something that will actually work
unfortunately it is so far along
it's the classic example of once a
weapons system gets far enough along it
has so much support no matter how bad it
is it's the first trillion dollar weapon
system in history I wanted to succeed
but frankly I've been fighting at every
step of the way we're at the value
voters summit about 70% of Americans
think that religion is losing its
influence in American life do you agree
with that and is that a good thing or a
bad thing or it doesn't really matter
one way or the other I think it matters
I tried to say my remarks today our
judeo-christian principles are under
assault in ways that are almost
unprecedented the first people that Isis
wants to kill are Christians and we need
a resurgence of judeo-christian
principles and what about in America I
mean did somebody like Kim Davis who is
headlining tonight was she right not to
actually perform her elected duties I
think she was right in that she can
exercise the dictates of her conscience
and everyone should respect that I do
not believe that therefore she should
inviolate the law she should have just
said I refuse to do it just like Hobby
Lobby case which we won because those
people were allowed to exercise their
religious beliefs by the United States
Supreme what are the limits of religious
exceptions or exemptions to law so let's
say that somebody an elected official or
Hobby Lobby says we don't want to serve
blacks because of our theology is that
legitimate that as you know that was
decided in the civil rights struggle in
the 60s and 70s that we said that people
are have the right to do not have the
right to refuse people because on the
basis of the color of their skin as you
know that was decided with the Civil
Rights Act with Kim Davis you're saying
she should not have forbid the other
clerks so to perform this I think that
the other clerks no I think the other
courage should exercise their conscience
as well what do you think Kim Davis
could say I don't want to perform this
but she should not have said to the
other clerks they could not I don't
think she she could prohibit the two
that's what I think she could encourage
others to take to follow her lead right
but I'm not sure she it's just as we can
tell her what the dictates of her
conscience are I don't think she could
tell her employees the dictates of their
conscience and once she agreed to do
that they let her out of jail
that's my understanding should should we
allow more legal immigration no and we
have exactly the right number of people
coming they're legal I think the key to
it is not so much to people who are
coming in because we're a nation of
immigrants but we have to have a secure
border so that people will come legally
that's where I don't want to spin off
too far with the verified portion of our
legislation that if you're an employer
and somebody comes to you without the
right documentation and you hire them
you're gonna go to jail so the
government is going to validate every
employment decision in the country
national leaders know someone comes into
this country and goes to someone for
work they just like they have to have a
valid social security card they have to
have a valid documentation that they're
in this country legally that's not it
but Israel I mean you got to check with
the government say oh yeah these
documents are okay doesn't that allow
the government so you don't have to
validate everything so check the
government when you're born
that's a birth certificate you know
check with the government last I checked
you don't go to a hospital and validate
with the government what you do is from
someone's born they get a birth
certificate right there you go so one on
the side you're a real jerk telling me
okay I'm only a faker
faked her
the one of the with the one of the
concerns that were traveling with this
was a jerk with the speaker's
resignation announcement this morning
senator Cruz was asked if you thought
that leader McConnell should follow
Speaker Boehner into retirement and he
said that would be a question for the
Republican Conference to decide there's
what your view on what the Republican
Conference would think of such a
suggestion leadership I'm sure okay one
more from reason TV because it's such a
bear yeah that's right away ask about
the Jones Act so what why why do so many
people about 70 percent of people think
the government's going in the wrong
direction because because we're not
responding they see failure even of
Republicans to be more United there is
various concern about out there about
the responsiveness of government to the
people and we are seeing that in a
variety of manifestation what is the
main one main thing that the government
should be working on now between now and
the election to get done that would
actually change the economy and we
change the environment a balanced budget
amendment to the Constitution in my view
if we got that going down the track we
could easily get 32 states that required
agreement from them and that's something
that you would Justin Amash agree on
sure yeah absolutely I know of no other
single act because that would force us
to eliminate the spending which you like
the question that you asked tough
decisions you would have to be made is a
pot legalization a good idea I don't
think so
I'd leave it up to the people but I
think it's a gateway drug and I'm not
gonna change a gateway drug away from
beer is that the problem should have
feet decided at the state level or at
the federal level we just mentioned one
other thing to you in the Northeast and
the Midwest right now there's a heroin
overdose epidemic in case you missed it
and that heroin is being manufactured in
Mexico and it is flooding the market
because it's so cheap it's cheaper than
oxycontin and we are seeing an epidemic
of heroin overdose deaths what is the
evidence for that what what I mean how
many people join in Vermont I mean we
hear about this but yeah but I mean
there double and triple from like six to
18 or not you know thousands of people
are due upon thousand think if you asked
I think if you asked any governor you
wouldn't say the war on drugs is working
right I would say that in the case and
is a winnable it's a winner poison
Speaker Boehner announced his
resignation
it's exceeded I have no favorite to
succeed him I leave that up to that
house representatives they think were
snobs in the cinah day anyway so I would
not resume rise tell him yes although I
know I knew he was getting weird Getti
what getting tired okay
alright thank you you come and visit
with us and I promise you we'll have a
good fight
you